along europe's eastern flank the
soldiers of the ukrainian army are
digging in
over the horizon russia's military
continues to mass a hundred thousand
soldiers and a week of diplomacy has
delivered nothing but stalemate now the
americans say they believe russia is
looking for a reason to invade and if
they can't find one they'll create one
well this is straight out of the russian
playbook to try to
through sabotage operations through
false flag operations through
blaming the other guy
to create that pretext to give an excuse
to go in
or to make it look like the ukrainians
were the aggressors when in fact the
first aggression was perhaps even done
by russians against russians to blame
the ukrainians so it's all very
dangerous in the way they operate
under three presidencies victoria
newland has had a focus on ukraine and
russia she is now under secretary of
state just put this moment in context
for us how serious is it how worried
should are you and how worried should we
be
well mark it's extremely worrying you
know a nation does not deploy a hundred
thousand troops on the border of another
nation
and put its saboteurs inside the country
without some malign and aggressive
intent
russia insists that all this is part of
an exercise it has dismissed the false
flag accusations as nonsense its
diplomats say the aggressor is nato an
alliance advancing east that must be
counted
nato has no gripes with russia unless
russia is coming for us we've lived side
by side since the end of the cold war
some 30 years is america prepared to go
to war with russia
if it invades ukraine
what we are talking about here is
helping the ukrainians to defend
themselves and preparing massive
consequences economic and political for
moscow if it
walks away from the diplomatic table and
chooses aggression instead and we all
have to do that we can't allow countries
to change international borders by force
we'll have a free-for-all out there in
the world
but president putin already did that he
did that in crimea he did and we know
from history that sanctions don't tend
to work so you know
if they do invade what then that
question hasn't been answered what will
you
america do if russia goes ahead and
invades beyond sanctions what we're
preparing this time is far more severe
and painful for russia economically in
terms of its potential complete economic
isolation from the global financial
system as well as political isolation
the good news is that neither side has
ditched the diplomacy just yet talks
continue at many levels
and soldiers on both sides of the border
await orders mark stone sky news
you